most of you if not by intelligence by
the fact that isn't there aren't that
many other things you could do I have
realized a limiting Sanger situation
isn't it right and you probably could
see that either before you knew what the
question was because you can see what
the ratio is right so you remember you
get a living song where if you take the
absolute value of the ratio it should be
less than one this definitely fits that
right the reason why relates to this
question is because the limiting some is
exactly or after the living some being
what we approach as n tends toward
infinity right now by the way
it's crucial that you get that little
bit at the end this is as n approaches
infinity okay and can never equal
infinity infinity is a very helpful
imaginary concept for us and for
mathematicians but in real life when you
actually give you medicine to someone
infinity is not a number you can get
sued because you don't think the kind of
dying before you got to infinity number
of doses okay so this is important
because of the numbers we get you later
on you'll have an important implication
ok so just keep that in backing like
what is the living son a living son for
sorry I'll just use an S is equal to hey
on what - on which you would recognize
it's just the sum of a GP - this has
been on the top which tend to be tens
two or one okay now the reason I've gone
straight here instead of for instance
getting a general term 2n is because
this doesn't get me any closer to this
right I already know what a and r are
okay so uh
because they are anyway outside now
what's the best time who will hours he
wants the comma right here okay and then
you do you really careful here right
this is why we build them from scratch
think about this how is this thing
growing what terms are getting added on
right what's the term that stays still
the first term okay it's not gonna be
this term here that sounds growing
constantly okay instead it's going to be
this term finally on the end right so
I'm considering as we've often do in
financial situations as well I'm
considering a series in Reverse okay so
my a will be that ten times three
quarters okay importantly it's not him
something like that which comes back to
our definition of what we call it m in
the beginning all right on the bottom
we've got one - the common ratio the
name is kerstin numbers okay which
arrives you after thing I can't now
the astute among you would notice
automatically if I get to 30 that's a
that's at the end of so I really should
call this n I get to the end of song
whatever interval and I'll at 30 and
then at the beginning of agent who I
should be adding 10 right so when I add
10 to this should I should I get to the
number that I'm not meant to get to so
can some explain why is the question
whether correctly or how can we account
for it why is it that I really never
can't get to 40 even though this is what
the limit is
the minute a customer by alluding the
fact that the limiting some it's a
minute right so it's what you're getting
to you're approaching it you never
actually get there just like an
asymptote right you can get close but
you never get there okay so see the
limiting some um the limit of this is
zero I don't actually get to zero in the
same way I never get to the okay so it's
a bit tricky say M equals 30
as if M was some real number somewhere M
is 30 which is real just like I let your
fence okay might actually get there
since I could never get to 30 I could
never get to for you by adding 10 okay
now it's important that you don't finish
just here okay because this doesn't
answer the question or you found a
number good for you it's my medal right
I actually have to conclude in some way
okay so what am I going to say as the
only way you put down should pretend as
the limiting son
or maybe four to the end of each
interval
is 30 milligrams
this is probably a long way of saying it
maybe you don't have to include all this
but that means that the patient's body
will never actually get to 30 milligrams
right so the patient's body will contain
less than sorry
listening 30 milligrams right at the end
of any
therefore adding ten administering a new
dose will never actually will be less
than 40 milligrams
do you remember I said right at the
beginning okay
that's mm yep this one here where we
defined our terms would make things
easier or harder for us right so I guess
in retrospect we probably could have
made our conclusion a little more
concise and not have to go with this 30
40 business by redefining em how'd you
find it I suppose you could say because
actually that's when you have the most
right because if you think about the
beginning of your tour and the end you
always got more in the beginning because
by the end your is the second you've
progressed you're losing more and more
now